che cosa vuol dire essere alla guida
della missione scientifica in antartide
la base di ricerca internazionale
concordia si trova in cima alla calotta
polare è un luogo estremamente le moto
si trova a 1.200 chilometri dalla base
sulla costa che le forniscono un
supporto logistico e le condizioni di
vita sono estreme siamo 4.000 metri di
altitudine e la temperatura in estate è
di meno 50 gradi centigradi e in inverno
c'è un distrutto gli 80 gradi sotto zero
la penta elizabeth station dove mi trovo
adesso invece una base belga si trova
dalla parte dell'antartide che si
affaccia sul sudafrica ed è il primo
edificio a emissioni zero dell'antartide
i progetti da realizzare sono molti
oltre ai carotaggi sul ghiaccio ci sono
le misurazioni in quota gli strumenti da
installare che permettono che di
campionare l'area varie altezze
organizzare le spedizioni alla costa per
studiare l'hiv shelf i telescopi da
installare per cercare pianeti
extrasolari la neve da sciogliere per
catturare i micro meteoriti strumenti da
installare per studiare le interazioni
terra sole e prevenire le tempeste
solari che possono essere devastanti per
un telescopio in orbita nello spazio
e poi naturalmente c'è una base da
gestire e le manutenzioni da fare in
qualsiasi condizione questa sola
maschera il mio respiro congelato
il completamento da mettere in gioco in
questo genere di missioni sono
moltissime e le risorse o decisamente
limitate il gruppo in formato da
specialisti di ogni genere e nello
stesso team ti puoi trovare un ex
militare che è stato per anni
responsabile della sala macchine di un
sommergibile un ricercatore celebre per
essere stato il precursore nello
sviluppo dei modelli climatici
l'ex cuoco di una famosa star
hollywoodiana un incursore esperto di
arti marziali un ex ingegnere della
formula 1 un pilota canadese è un
esploratore anche vinile grafia qui
insomma il gruppo evidentemente
multiculturale multidisciplinare e
soprattutto composto da individui dalle
personalità più disparate l'antartide è
il regno dell'incertezza
la natura è forte le nostre conoscenze
sono ancora molto limitate e una
logistica di una missione è estremamente
complessa essere alla guida di un
progetto che si vuole realizzare nell
estrema incertezza significa molto di
più che navigare a vista
vuol dire avere molti scopi poco tempo
risorse limitate
è una situazione da considerare
costantemente con attenzione perché gli
imprevisti drammatici sono sempre in
agguato e l'astrazione devono essere
tempestive precise ed attive e a
pensarci meglio essere alla guida di una
missione scientifica in antartide è come
essere il capitano di una nave di pirati
che viaggia senza motore in mezzo al
mare in tempesta
in effetti il capitano di una nave dei
pirati che viaggia in mezzo al mare in
tempesta io lo so ora tra voi c'è
qualcuno che si sta domandando meno 50
gr di freddo 4.000 metri di altitudine
la mancanza d'aria una base da gestire
mille problemi e un ambiente
estremamente pericoloso perché in
antartide
beh intanto dovete sapere che esiste una
malattia che è il mal dant artide che
hanno specie di mal d'africa e chi è
stato per la prima volta in antartide
poi inevitabilmente ci vuole tornare
certo certi paesaggi fai un po fatica a
dimenticateli paesaggi come questo le
drive halley che sono una zona
dell'antartide talmente arida che non si
ferma neppure il ghiaccio e poi ci
vivono delle creature straordinarie qui
vivono dei licheni che sono in grado di
arrestare i loro processi vitali quando
le condizioni di vita sono troppo
estreme ma non vanno in letargo mettono
letteralmente la loro vita in pausa e
poi la riprendono quando le condizioni
sono più gradevoli ma il mal darti del
fatto di un sacco di cose ci sono gli
incontri con le persone
la sfida è la bellezza di fare un
progetto comune la convivenza
forse una conferenza non è la prima cosa
a cui pensi quando pensi con nostalgia
in antartide
però tra i vari aspetti che ci spingono
a tornare questa sera vi voglio parlare
di uno in particolare ed è il fatto che
l'antartide ci espone continuamente ma
continuamente all'incertezza e questa
cosa fa sì che la nostra consapevolezza
della complessità di cui ha fatto il
mondo aumenti una specie di palestra una
palestra di complessità per esempio una
delle caratteristiche che si sviluppano
in antartide è la resilienza la
resilienza lo sapete una proprietà
naturale di tutti gli esseri viventi
in pratica un essere vivente che perde
la resilienza difficilmente riesce a
sopravvivere
e ho trovato questa definizione sono due
ricercatori che hanno dedicato un intera
un intero volume alla resilienza e la
definiscono così la capacità di un
sistema di un'impresa di una persona di
mantenere il suo scopo principale la sua
integrità di fronte a circostanze
drasticamente mutate in pratica a
livello psicologico è la capacità di
adattarsi alle trasformazioni mentre si
trasformano in pratica è la capacità di
saper trasformare le situazioni
trasformare anche noi stessi
pur rimanendo radicati conservando il
nostro cento
un po come un albero che in mezzo alla
turbolenza della tempesta si piega ma
non si spezza
ecco credo che la resilienza sia un
elemento veramente importante perché in
antartide ti trovi sempre in balia
dell'incertezza e all'inizio è veramente
difficile perché le spedizioni non si
organizzano più come una volta quando ai
tempi di shackleton per esempio si
sentivano i discorsi dei balenieri per
indirizzare il percorso della nave oggi
siamo abituati ad avere tutto sotto
controllo per esempio anche la
spedizione in antartide può far
affidamento alle tecnologie più
sofisticate come le immagini satellitari
con le quali possiamo vedere per esempio
l'andamento del pack in mezzo al mare oi
tre passi in tempo reale però anche se
ci prepariamo anche se utilizziamo tutte
le tecnologie che abbiamo a disposizione
alla fine in antartide succede sempre
qualcosa di inaspettato sempre qualcosa
che poi scatena tutta una serie di
eventi a catena e distrugge tutti i
nostri piani non importa se li abbiamo
fatti perfettamente e questa
un'esperienza abbastanza scioccante come
per esempio due anni fa mi trovavo alla
base concordia e la cosa che si trova in
cima alla calotta polare è una base dove
sono stata più spesso dove più spesso
fatto il capo spedizione e quell anno
sembrava che tutto andasse secondo i
nostri piani
stavamo aspettando il rifornimento di
carburante dalla costa di solito per
sicurezza abbiamo una riserva di
carburante
che ci garantisce ovviamente di avere
un'autonomia per un anno però quell'anno
per la prima volta da quando è stata
costruita la base non l'avevamo perché
l'anno precedente avevamo deciso di dare
tutta la nostra scorta a un grande
progetto di ricerca era un campionamento
di ghiaccio fatto con una traversa che
doveva attraversare il plateau ma
avevamo calcolato tutti i rischi e del
resto poi a giorni sarebbe arrivata la
nostra nave avrebbe attraccato alla
costa e poi il carburante sarebbe
arrivato a noi come avveniva
effettivamente da 15 anni tutti gli anni
invece in quei giorni una nave russa che
non c'entrava niente con noi che si
trovava al più di 1.300 chilometri di
distanza lancia un sos e questo evento
si è scatenato su di noi come il battito
d'ali di una farfalla che scatenano
uragano dall'altra parte del mondo
perché la nostra nave è stata richiamata
in soccorso e quando l'emergenza è
finita dopo 14 giorni fortunatamente
tutti i passeggeri sono stati tratti in
salvo e la nostra nave ha cercato di
fare rotta di nuovo verso la base
francese che la stava aspettando
questa è la situazione che ha trovato il
pallino rosso indica la posizione della
nave quello giallo quello della base
francese in cui era attesa in mezzo
c'erano 100 km di pac
una situazione che i francesi di quella
base non avevano mai visto in
cinquant'anni di spedizione noi a
concordia siamo rimasti senza carburante
per tutta la stagione è ovviamente tutta
la nostra pianificazione tutta tutto il
nostro lavoro di un anno è andato in
fumo
abbiamo dovuto riorganizzarci con quello
che avevamo e rifare tutto da capo
ecco a me sembra che l'antartide
assomigli molto alla vita molto di più
delle nostre esperienze urbane
perché anche nella vita ci capita che
facciamo i piani ci organizziamo
pensiamo tutti gli scenari possibili
cominciamo a costruire e poi
all'improvviso accade l'inaspettato
qualcosa che manda tutto all'aria
e dobbiamo riorganizzarci con quello che
abbiamo effettivamente un'esperienza
scioccante ma è più scioccante
quando sei il capo spedizione in
antartide perché lì è la responsabilità
anche di tutti gli altri
e all'inizio confesso che è stato
abbastanza dura è stato un po stressante
solo che dopo un po ho cominciato a
rendermi conto che avevo familiarizzato
con questa incertezza con l'imprevisto
che avevo capito qualcosa magari in
qualcosa di più sulla complessità del
mondo per esempio mi ero accorta di
essere e resiliente quella di cui parlo
è la resilienza mentale che cos'è realtà
è un concetto molto complesso ed è molto
difficile definirlo chiuderlo in una
definizione
però io ho pensato di sintetizzarlo in
tre elementi fondamentali il primo è la
capacità di leggere le trasformazioni
perché si sa in natura tutto cambia e
magari siamo noi che ci illudiamo che le
cose siano sempre le stesse
e allora bisogna imparare a leggere
quelli che si chiamano i segnali deboli
cioè quei segnali che stanno nel
presente e che hanno in sé un embrione
del futuro che verrà
in antartide questo è obbligatorio e
allora abbiamo imparato a stare sempre
un po in allerta anche quando la
situazione è più tranquilla possibile
sapete come fanno gli animali che si
rilassano sembra che si stiano godendo
il momento ma sono sempre pronti a
drizzare le orecchie sempre pronti a
scattare se qualcosa non va e qui
veniamo al secondo punto la capacità di
reagire rapidamente senza nascondersi
dietro alibi senza stare a pensare a
quello che sarebbe dovuto essere e
questo ci serve per la nostra lucidità
mentale perché noi purtroppo non
possiamo fare come rick eni e mettere la
nostra vita in pausa se qualcosa non va
effettivamente lo stanno studiando ma
per ora bisogna
aspettare e dobbiamo agire rapidamente e
poi c'è il terzo elemento che è la
capacità di esplorare e ricombinare con
creatività alle cose che abbiamo trovato
lungo il cammino della nostra
esplorazione esplorare per me è
fondamentale e lo so non è facile perché
per esplorare bisogna uscire dalla
comfort zone
bisogna mettersi in gioco bisogna
aprirsi bisogna mettersi in dubbio e
delle volte può essere anche pericoloso
però esplorando ci si espone ai nuovi
punti di vista
alle nuove esperienze a nuove emozioni
nuove idee e questo è importante perché
crea diversità dentro di noi
crea risorse e quelle risorse ci saranno
molto utili quando la nostra zona di
confort si starà trasformando sta
evolvendo in qualcos'altro
e allora dovremo affrontare un problema
e li attingeremo a quelle risorse che
abbiamo sviluppato nella nostra
esplorazione e dovremmo ricombinarli in
modo creativo per trovare una soluzione
al problema che dobbiamo affrontare
magari anche un problema che non si era
mai visto questa foto è la foto della
mia ultima spedizione alla princess
elizabeth station dell'anno scorso anche
in quel caso era il capospedizione e
forse è la spedizione più difficile che
ha dovuto affrontare perché quando siamo
arrivati ci siamo accorti che la nostra
base era stata sabotata e saccheggiata
qualcuno aveva organizzato una
spedizione parallela e aveva portato via
gran parte della nostra attrezzatura tra
cui tutta la scorta di cibo e gran parte
dell'attrezzatura dell'infermeria
allora vi confesso ho pensato davvero
che fosse finita e soprattutto
mi sono stupita e pensavo che in dodici
anni di esperienza in antartide mi fossi
abituata anche essere stupita ma questa
non me la sarei mai immaginata però poi
ho fatto una riunione con il mio team
abbiamo analizzato le risorse che ci
erano rimaste incluse le competenze che
avevamo all'interno del team e abbiamo
deciso che non era ancora arrivato il
momento di mollare e così oltre che
hanno spedizione di quattro mesi in
veramente in condizioni molto difficili
siamo riusciti a portare a termine tutti
i programmi di ricerca e in particolare
ce n'è stato uno che si è trasformato in
quella nel classico problema che diventa
un'opportunità perché tra le varie
modifiche che abbiamo fatto abbiamo
fatto una modifica la pianificazione di
ricerca e abbiamo accorpato due
programmi scientifici che inizialmente
dovevano lavorare separatamente e beh
quella contaminazione si è rivelata
molto efficace per cui i ricercatori
hanno trovato dai risultati di ricerca
molto più interessanti insieme che se
avessero lavorato separatamente
e allora tutto questo per dire che
secondo me la capacità di affrontare
l'incertezza di non perdersi d'animo di
di sapere che il mondo complesso e di
essere resilienti sono veramente
competenze fondamentali soprattutto in
questo momento storico viviamo in un
mondo che è sempre più complesso e è
sempre più incerto e sviluppare
competenze come la resilienza sono
fondamentali e così io sto scommettendo
su questo in questo momento sto
lavorando unendo lo studio del pensiero
complesso alle esperienze di vita in
antartide e li sto portando nelle
aziende nelle organizzazioni è in
contatto al contatto quotidiano delle
persone perché essere resilienti per
esempio significa sapere che anche se la
situazione fuori si sta trasformando in
un modo che sembra caotico tu hai
un'altra scelta oltre che subirla perché
non sai dove sta andando la situazione
puoi trasformare quella
l'opzione oppure puoi trasformare te
stesso pur rimanendo ancorato altro
centro e credo che queste competenze
siano veramente importanti per il nostro
futuro perché sono fondamentali per
sentirci attori del nostro futuro che è
quello che noi costruiamo tutti i giorni
con le nostre scelte
vi ringrazio